[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
the handmaid's tale
season 4 episode 5 chicago
this is directed by the same director
from last episode christina cho
this is written by john herrera and nina
fiori
so with this review we'll break it down
to two parts i'll start with the nick
lawrence and lydia story lines and then
we'll finish off with june and janine
so i absolutely loved this first scene
with aunt lydia it might actually be my
favorite scene of the episode because
it has great setup in one scene with
payoff in that same scene what i'm
talking about
is that we see inside these ants hanging
out which we don't get enough to see
right we never really see
their whole situation what they're doing
day to day but you see they're drinking
tea
they are playing chess and they're
playing cards and they're doing this
religious puzzle
of course it's a picture of mary with
all these female angels around her
looking up to her of course this is what
ants aspire to be
but what i'm talking about with set up
and payoff i love how they had
the aunt say to aunt lydia while she's
on the treadmill you know do you want us
to deal you in and she's like no thanks
she's more focused on getting back to
work
and now seeing these new handmaids come
in and i'll explain the payoff in a
minute but what's interesting is this
character of aunt ruth coming in who's a
towering aunt ruth she's a tall
person and it works really well because
it's making aunt lydia look
weak and you see how the camera work
here is purposely pointing down at aunt
lydia most of the scenes here
i love the shot here of aunt ruth
looking down at aunt lydia it reminds me
of serena joy looking down at june just
that towering presence
but you see she's in former lydia
they're gonna replace the lost children
in no time with these new handmaids but
lydia you know isn't right away sent to
go
take care of those handmaids she has to
be reinstated first and it's
heartbreaking to her because ruth's like
those girls are not your concern anymore
and even when lydia's pleading to ruth
like can you just speak to the
commanders on my behalf to have me
reinstated ruth just doesn't care and
she's like
it's your time to rest but that
payoff i'm talking about is right here
when ruth
points to the table where they invite
her to play before and she's like oh
good there's an empty seat at the table
godspeed just trying to put lydia where
she does not want to be
playing cards with other ants she wants
to do her work so i thought that was
just brilliantly laid out and how you
really do a scene well
now we see commander lawrence speaking
to the council
and nick is on that council and what
frustrates me a bit
is i'm happy that we finally got clear
how much he actually knew about lawrence
here
and his involvement with june which i
don't think
was made clear enough earlier in the
season and it added a confusion like i
had complained about like
how did nick get him off so easy without
him being put on the wall
but you learn this episode that really
lydia knows his involvement but they
don't know
to the extent of how much stuff
lawrence did this council so now we see
that here but i just wish we
had known that earlier was a little
confusing but what lawrence is doing
here is he's proposing a ceasefire
on contested borders and he's saying
this is in chicago california and texas
and he's saying it's the moral high
ground to take to ease the trade
restrictions
but really the other day he's doing this
for june and i like his line where he's
like we can just hit him harder in
nevada when he's trying to justify
these guys that are hungry and he's
trying to sell it where he's like
unlike woman numbers don't lie i thought
this was just some really good humorous
writing for lawrence
but you see the council rejects his
proposal and nick has to save face
also rejects it but he's like to
lawrence i can't
vote ceasefire on a charge i'm leading
but you see this sets up now
lawrence and nick have this weird
tension between them
where they're helping each other but the
same time
they're testing each other and pushing
each other and kind of trying to get a
leg up on each other
how many times is this guy going to say
each other but lawrence is explaining to
nick
if we do this ceasefire it will help
june but nick's like i would know if
june is at one of these borders
but lawrence says it's a big country
commander the eyes can't see everything
again giving nick that shove he really
needs because he always gets cold feet
and hesitates
so what i did love is when we go back to
lydia that we see her looking at her
reflection in the mirror
and there's two lydias there right and
it's showing that duality of her
character that internal
conflict she has we all have this we're
all duel in a sense right and
two sides of our head battling but lydia
is a really complicated character
and what's interesting about her
struggle is that
to me she really isn't likable at all i
don't give her any redemption here
i think that's long gone but that's me
but she's that case of someone who
has a belief in it in this system of
gilead and we'll see later
she says this in her speech to her new
handmaids but you know
doesn't like the stuff that goes on
behind the scenes with what men do
to these handmaids and she's always kind
of been enabling of that by turning
a blind eye even though she doesn't like
it the reason i'm bringing this up right
now though is i don't know
how we can get to redemption for her i
mean she's done so much wrong and she
still believes in the gilead system
which is still
rape these ceremonies are rape that
she's still supporting so
i don't know how we can pull this off is
what i'm saying but we get this verbal
ping pong now between
lydia and lawrence and she blackmails
him basically saying all this dirt she
knows about him
but they're trying to get out what they
need from each other and
what he needs is to get put on the
council again she can help him with that
by giving him blackmail on the other
commanders
but she wants to get reinstated as an
aunt but she also gets in the deal that
she will have june at the end of the day
and do what she wants with her
you know lawrence doesn't want this but
he's clearly saying yes here to get what
he needs but that's going to be an
interesting
conflict later on when that comes up and
i'm sure that's really setting up
lawrence's final redemption of the day
by protecting june from lydia
but we see here nick meets with these
two martha's
that are part of mayday and it's like
good cop bad cop here one of them's like
jun's got all these people killed you
know you should just forget about her
you'd be better off this really is like
again two sides of reddit these two
martha's
the other one's like nice about it and
she's telling him where june is
saying that she heard there's two
handmaids near the border of chicago so
this now confirms to nick oh my god like
june is at this border that lawrence is
trying to cease fire
so lydia now is reinstated right she's
putting her baton back on
she puts the pen on i really like the
scene with her new handmaids here
but you see she's saying stuff that she
didn't really say in the beginning of
her
career as an aunt where she's like
you'll be tested by wicked men
and they will try to lead you astray and
when they do i will be here
to listen like i said before this is
lydia in a nutshell this is her
character she believes in these
religious ways of gilead and their
practices but doesn't believe in the
stuff that
is actually hypocritical that they do
behind the scenes
so we'll see where they go with lydia
sterling that again i think it's just
going to be hard to sell her
redemption arc if she is still okay with
the ceremonies they have
to have these handmaids get pregnant
that's my one concern
how do you sell that and get us on board
as the audience
so lawrence is back on the council here
all seems like it's going to plan and
good now because
they approve of his plan of ceasing fire
but there's a catch and that basically
what lawrence had to do to get them to
agree to this
was that they would do one more aerial
bombing
before they actually cease fire and that
nick would be the one to order the
strike
you can tell by the way lawrence and
nick are looking at each other that
there is a rift between them
again i'm talking about this leg up on
each other and there's like this pride
thing going on like who's really
telling who what to do and now lawrence
has more power because he's back on the
council because he got
this blackmail from lydia about the
commander so nick can't really
command him anymore but it's lawrence
putting the ball back in nick's
court here to now make the next move and
do what needs to be done
so this was a really nice surprise and
exciting like oh my god like what is
nick gonna do here this is crazy
because we know where these bombs are
going where janine and june are so
speaking of janine and june
let's go to their side of the episode
before we get back to the whole aerial
bombings
so already what's heartbreaking about
how it opens up with june and jeanine's
story is that
while june's laying down thinking of
luke
we see that janine is sleeping with this
creeper stephen
from last episode who took advantage of
her of course that character's name is
steven
great but we'll see what jun's character
here is her conflict is that she's used
to being in charge but this is all
stephen's call we learn and what they
do and that she just wants to use these
guns and fight
but that's not their approach this camp
they're very reserved
but what i did like what they did with
jun's character here is that you see the
next day she's washing her handmaid's
outfit
she's holding onto a tight throughout
the episode which will eventually eat
her having to trade it in
but it's interesting it's like her not
letting go
of it and her time as a handmaid
and how that's always going to stay with
her too which i like they're kind of
opening that door like i was talking
about with rita
when she got to cannon really seeing how
jun's gonna adjust
but i feel that same disgust june feels
where
you see steven teaching janine how to
use a gun
and he's all flirty with her and she's
happy with him it's like
you know what the real thing that's
going on there is just sick and twisted
on stephen's part
so june when they run into a
dead body they find of a soldier she
learns about the nighthawks from stephen
so
june likes the sound of the nighthawks
they just kill soldiers
they are true rebels and they're
fighters and that's what she wants to do
again that's why i'm saying she's
enamored with all these scenes where
she's looking at the guns at the trade
at the one stephen's holding she just
wants to take these things and fight
back
but you know what's interesting is it
leads to this tense scene
in this shop where the soldiers show up
and they're hiding and she's like
mad at stephen because he's not just
shooting at the soldier but he's like
hey
what happens when they don't report back
more patrols
more soldiers unfortunately i kind of
agree with steven here it's like
you know june sometimes gets so chaotic
and emotional in the way she
fights that she doesn't take a beat
sometimes to just think
and realize that every action that
seems the right in the moment may not be
and
kind of weigh all the options and i
think that actually makes more sense
what stephen was saying but i i do
wonder they gave so
much time to june and looking at guns
this episode making a big point of it
there really wasn't a payoff
about it this episode though so i don't
know if they're setting up a story where
she's going to learn to not be as like
war hungry let's say or fighting or if
they're just
a reminder and saying that they do have
to fight which kind of
gets talked about here with her and
janine but we'll get to that in a second
first i want to talk about this scene
relax at the trade post
and there's important character moments
like this guy brad just
wants to be friends with june here we
don't really know his clear intentions
and like june we're not trusting right
and she just says to him she's not
interested but janine's like wow
she's like you're really making friends
here but it's the complete opposite of
them where janine's very
friendly very trusting open and
innocent right where june just knows the
reality of this world right now she's
very closed book and it's shown in their
costume design which is really good
because
janine you see she's even got this new
eye patch her whole
color palette here is the same as that
camp she blends right in she's fitting
right in where
jun's like just sticking out like a sore
thumb with that yellow
sweater and staying on the outs so what
was really interesting here though is
when
janine finds this baseball cap that she
wants to get for stephen
you know in the screener it has a cubs
logo on it and of course that's because
elizabeth moss is a huge diehard cubs
fan i'm wondering if
in the episode itself if you guys let me
know in the comments if it does have the
cubs logo because
in the trailers all these scenes there's
no logo on the hat
so i don't know if that was something to
do with they couldn't maybe
have the logo in the trailers for
certain royalty reasons
who knows but i am curious i've actually
kept that in the episode
but it's pushing now june confronting
janine more and more about like i don't
want this guy taking advantage of you
and janine's always fighting back like
look it's consensual
i really like this guy but the other day
from an outsider's point of view like
june's
you really know what the real deal is
with this guy stephen i feel like we've
all been there with a friend
or sibling where you see they're dating
someone who is trouble and you can see
what they're doing with the person in it
really can't but you also have to find
this line of like when do you back off
but like i'm talking about going back to
her having trouble letting go of this
handmade cloak
but she does the right thing by giving
hers in to make sure that janine gets
that hat
that janine we know really wants and
it's a nice
gesture by june but i really love they
showed even when the guy's putting the
cloaks away
june looks at those cloaks and like
flinches so it's just interesting to see
how
her mind's gonna adjust to not being a
handmade anymore
so where we really see the main conflict
of this episode between
june and janine happen is at night when
they talk and june tells janine she
wants to just go let's find these
nighthawks and fight
but janine is like no i'm comfortable
here i want to have a child
we can be moms together and she's just
striving for
a normal life here and she's like the
world needs more american babies
and then jean's like you sound like aunt
lydia but janine's like no you're like
aunt lydia because you're bossy you're
judgmental
but again june hammers home which kind
of got a little repetitive here writing
wise with her
again saying to janine this guy's taking
advantage of you and
janine's like no it's consensual stop
trying to make yourself feel better by
helping me
and jun's like i don't want to see you
get hurt but janine's like
maybe you should have thought that with
alma and brianna
i think that was also repetitive i think
because we saw that last episode pretty
much almost word for
the same line and point made so kind of
felt like they were just
pulling back some uh old hits here but
june has the disc of the season when she
says back okay
well i'm leaving tomorrow you can come
with me or stay
here and be of steven sizzle
got him but what this big fight leads to
is a really great scene
with janine and june the next day when
janine informs june that she's going
gonna stay
there's true love shown between these
two characters that go way back
and it's with the lines that june says
janine baby is gonna be lucky to have
you
and janine says back well these rebels
are gonna be lucky to have you and i
love janine gives her the hat and says
something to remember me by
now this has way more meaning because we
know how this episode ends
which we'll get to but june says how can
i forget you
beautifully delivered by elizabeth moss
and janine says who can forget the girl
with one eye
and the great line is when jean says
back i think you're beautiful
whew there comes the water works for me
i thought i was going to go episode not
crying but it happened
just again props to madeleine brewer and
elizabeth moss they are
true brilliant actresses and they just
kind of just worked off each other you
couldn't do it better in one scene
so june is in this big city right she's
walking alone i love seeing this new
setting like i was talking about i'm
happy this season is going
to these new locations things people
have wanted to see
and janine's already back this kind of
felt a little rushed
that she's already back after we just
had that really good goodbye moment
and it's going to go into my issues with
the end of this episode as we're getting
into this but she says i feel we are
safer together
handmaids always walk in twos remember
love that line
but this is where it gets crazy because
you see these planes coming in from
nick's attack and the bombs and it's
right where june and janine is so this
was insane
and june rolls over after getting hit
by all this debris and grabs the hat
that again
right now is gonna symbolize janine to
her but
in this big moment at the end of the
episode i have four
issues here and it really hurts this
episode as a whole for me because
you want to stick the landing right no
pun intended with the planes so issue
number one
i didn't like the cover by coldplay here
to fix you
hell no just give me the regular version
and the problem even if they give me the
regular version i don't think this song
works for this moment i just
don't think the lyrics match up well and
having
moira come in it just doesn't really
click on me and
having the cover version is really
tropey right now you see it in so many
trailers for movies and shows and it's
like the
hipster starbucks version of coldplay
i don't want to hear it i don't think it
works it's just kind of rolling your
eyes a bit
my other issue here is that the moment
june gets up and is screaming janine we
are feeling that in that moment just
like june and our number one concern in
our mind is where
is janine so why this is an issue for me
is because
having moira come in right at that
moment
makes me care less about her coming in
because my head is on where is janine i
can't fit in
being like oh my god moira's back like
it's cramming in two
very important emotions that need their
weight and time and answer
and it's it's fighting against each
other because i should be feeling that
feeling of like oh moira is back this is
amazing
best friends are united but i'm actually
more worried at the moment about where
janine i can't really care about that
my third complaint is why on earth did
the marketing team
for the show decide to show in the
trailers
moira in this exact moment finding june
why would they do that because this is
literally the midpoint of the season we
are at the end of episode five it's a
ten episode season
why would you show that big reveal it
takes away so much from it we knew this
was gonna happen
so there goes reveal for that and it's
not even like they threw it in
teasers or little promos or clips that
you might find deeper on the web it was
in the main trailer
and finally i do not like they did not
show us if janine died or not
i know it's a business move it's a
classic cliffhanger shows do to be like
oh we gotta get everyone talking about
is janine or live or not for like a week
but i don't think this is great move by
the handmaids so i don't think they
should get into that gimmicky
area and especially because we're
transitioning now to moira being in the
fold we're also going to have to squeeze
in an answer for jeanine that's going to
stay on people's minds so they better
give us an answer at least at the
beginning of next
episode or it's not going to leave us
it's too big of a character you can't
not tell us and it hurts the emotion of
the scene because
you're like am i crying or am i not
crying because i don't really know if
janine is dead or not and
this whole episode you know was written
as an episode of a character dying so
i'm gonna guess that she's gonna pass
away but
i don't know if she's dead or not and
that's frustrating and i think we should
know
right here to get the payoff for the
episode and it's weird because it's
trying to transition out now from
june's story to now going towards canada
but you can't leave that big hook
i just don't agree with it and i didn't
want to say this yet but now i'm
actually feeling it where
i did like the pace at the beginning of
the season moving location and getting
on with things not feeling filler
episodes but i did feel
this episode was rushed and i would have
liked a little more time with janine
and june maybe split up or if we're
gonna rush janine coming back maybe just
a little more time with janine and june
on the run
like i i don't think that was something
you should just jump out of i think we
finally got somewhere where
they're doing their own thing we're in
this new location it could have been i
think a little more interesting but now
it's kind of like all right we're taking
june
and now we're going to canada and i
can't put my finger on here it's just
how i feel
i don't even know if this is justified
saying but this episode for some reason
felt hollow and i think it's because i'm
not buying aunt lydia
being capable of redemption arc yet and
it's a shorter episode right i think
it's on like 43 minutes
so it's gonna add to that rush feeling
and it's stuff that i think they kind of
should have taken a little more time
with and it's not as tight as previous
episodes
that's thematically and this episode is
more
telly than showy in the past episodes
where it's a lot of dialogue heavy and
kind of just saying what you need to
hear where
you can literally look at the conflict
between janine
and june last episode it was way better
how they did it where it was a lot of
showing and you felt it through visual
language right and a little bit of
dialogue telling you but this was a lot
of just like
on the nose writing pulling some beats
we already saw from last episode with
their
fighting so i wasn't as crazy about this
episode but i still think it was it was
really good episode because it's still
handling still still quality
i still enjoyed it in the season as a
whole but i do have
some serious gripes this episode that i
didn't have with other ones so i'm
actually gonna give this one still an
8.5 because if it just stuck the landing
here
and went away from my heavy criticism
that final scene that you really need to
hit
in a big episode to make it all kind of
come together especially with an
important character like janine and
i'm worried that i hope to god they
didn't kill janine because she's a big
character and she's also like arguably
maybe
the most popular character on the show i
think she is
maybe right down below your thoughts
let's have that debate who is the most
popular character now who you like the
best
who do you think is the most loved by
fans and i'm gonna actually say
it's janine so does that help the show
when they kill that character
it never does so i hope they didn't but
we'll see let me know what you thought
this episode down below i love to hear
your thoughts i read every comment i try
to respond
to as many as i can i've done a bunch of
interviews with the cast about the
season so check out the links down below
it'll be the top comment i pin you don't
want to miss those
please follow me at stevenshow on
twitter instagram for more of me
and if you really like what i do here
i'd really appreciate if you could sign
up for my paypal link it's in my
description it's two dollars a month
it will help me do this full time one
day and make more videos for you guys
help me live my dream i'd really
appreciate that and if not again like i
said if you just subscribe to channel
that helps in so many ways you have no
idea
and praise be and i'll see you next week